metro police also responding to the
guilty verdict in the chauvin trial
orco mana continues our team coverage he
joins us live from metro headquarters
with how the department is reflecting on
its own policies orco
well brian metro under sheriff
christopher darcy says he believes the
jury held derrick chauvin accountable
now the focus here locally turns to
lvmpd and its ongoing efforts to improve
how officers interact with the public
it brought me tears to my eyes where
i couldn't stop crying reverend leonard
jackson describes his reaction to the
guilty verdict in the derrick chauvin
trial nearly one year after the death of
george floyd
this is true justice to achieve justice
in las vegas jackson works closely with
metro police he says collaboration is
crucial
we will stand and assure that the law
has changed that we enforce the proposed
changes in the positive change will take
place
there is no environment on this police
department for an officer
like derek shaubin metro undersheriff
christopher darcy says it's crucial to
keep police in check
changes were made to metro's use of
force policies last year
before floyd's death those include
prohibiting choke holds providing more
de-escalation training and mandating
officers intervene if another officer
uses improper force
the chauvin trial opening the door to
even more improvements
it gives us an opportunity to look
inward and look at other policies and
think
is there some other area maybe where
we're not looking at that we can make
those changes
advocates hope the verdict assures the
public that bad apples in law
enforcement will be caught
the ones that are bad are held
accountable we want bad cops found just
as much
as the citizens do we believe there's
always a way to improve what we do
what we don't like is for people just to
blame cops jackson says community
involvement will make a difference
positive change will take place without
support
metro says another way it hopes to
improve as a department
is by hiring more diverse officers to
better reflect our community
reporting live from metro headquarters
tonight orca mana 8 news now